hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil now
we've got Lucas here hey dumbass but
don't turn around if you're stupid and
an idiot alright so what we gonna do
about this well see ya hope you didn't
hear that
yeah how about this Kurt uncle YC just
giggling to himself doesn't make any
sense what the hell yeah I'm glad you're
so certain to my death and kamek kamek
in common in comic comic book villain
methodology hey buddy
yes yeah oh oh wow he put that up in a
quickie alright that killed off all the
connections researchers they were poking
around where they weren't supposed to
when I wasn't looking but I knew exactly
what they were up to probably didn't
have like having room to report to me so
I threw them in a cage with some molded
they [ __ ] their pants and begged for
their lives
I'm just worried I won't be able to hold
back from laughing when I make the
report that they've met with an
unfortunate accident probably good time
to cut ties the connection I'm the only
one who can really make good use of
Evelyn's mold okay that's weird what's
with all the mannequin heads though why
is he obsessed with mannequin heads what
am I seeing here I saw something Oh save
alright then looky cool okay anything
else here it's a fear oh oh that's the
way back okay
handgun ammo buyer for data got one get
set up for transmission who's buying
please tell me it's umbrella corporation
because that would make total sense
because I don't trust Sunbrella
corporation even if they did restructure
something just tells me there's bad news
all over the place oh yeah I forgot
about that guy
um uh uh how about a grenade would that
work I think it'd work would it work it
wouldn't work nah wait oh it does oh it
doesn't have any bullets oh okay well
that's handy well I was just four scares
then he doesn't have anything left
Wow all right fine then hello
you should have gone Aryan would have
found some bullets well you know emails
we know you're funneling info to someone
[Music]
friends the connections know about this
they don't strike me as the forgiving
type
whoa what the [ __ ] all right then go I
just gotta kill you well he ain't gonna
die I don't believe it it's over just
shut up an accepted Lucas
ah situation down here tell me something
I dunno
yeah I don't wanna be [ __ ] screwed
why am I still on him huh different like
I haven't been since we got here why was
he still was they still straddling him
why was it straddling him in the first
place
what's happening oh okay oh I just let
that happen then did i ah yeah gross oh
that's big oh whoa you are weird-looking
all right what do you do buddy hey I
don't like any of what you're doing
right now how about you take one of the
lose another wanna lose can I punch you
is that an option
can I punch you whoa whoa leapfrog all
right
Oh mother punch you oh I'm so gonna
punch you
ah wait why can't I punch you oh [ __ ]
that's not punchable oh yay
I thought he was gonna leapfrog again oh
whoa whoa whoa okay are you okay
Oh goddamn where's it going come on stop
skedaddle all over the world
okay ye that's too much skedaddle I
don't know I closed my eyes for a bit to
let you do whatever you're doing right
now but something tells me now in
retrospect that might have been a
terrible idea
oh it's so goopy on the ceiling let me
see what's in here oh wait oh hey how
about you don't do that oh that hurt a
lot okay well options are what [ __ ]
nil oh guy yeah flap flap flap oh oh he
don't look so good is he still alive is
he dying
oh yeah he's still alive not dying
everything I said was wrong
okay well that's a lot of contamination
yes a little weird huh what does that
mean what the hood thank you a guess how
that works and why that was set up in
here just for such an occasion as this
but I'll take it
sure
okay I gotta use those once I'm really
low not when I'm like at sixty I didn't
know that yeah yeah yeah get it what if
I use my super bullets on you is it
gonna work or is it gonna be just a
waste now I'll wait until I run out I
guess
yeah I hate it when you do the leapfrog
thing it doesn't bode well for me oh boy
am I starting to run low okay here we go
Super Bowl let's ho ho baby don't like
that oh you do not the answer is a
negative on that one alright I'm gonna
go get some oxygen I know God they know
whoa hey whoa hey okay God how much do
you need this is supposed to be like oh
I'm out of everything okay well this is
a problem I got a whole lot of nothing
that did nothing okay all right well
here we go oh yeah you're Lucas oh yeah
you you deserved that one I don't know
how I did that with a knife but I just
gonna assume that it's because I'm an
incredible badass so unbelievably
awesome in everything I do yeah I didn't
have any bullets left but shoot oh honey
now a shotguns left but okay I'll take
it Oh doh no snow it's like 50% come on
shoot the computer
there you go there you go yeah Chris
being a smart gets infected immediately
yeah makes sense I guess I should have
finished in the last episode but that
doesn't think we did a good here is it
Wesker is it Wesker tell me it's Wesker
who's packing up all this [ __ ] so while
I was down in the mines while I was down
in the mines dying with all my team of
the four of us that's all we really did
when things would go p-- that bad
they were just packing up all right
that's fascinating
okay but it's not over this episode is
not over yet because I'm gonna roll
right into the very next the next DLC
Thor's hammer site B ooh okay well I
don't I don't need any of that I'm going
into the next one with Joe all right now
Donna
get out of here we don't need this we
don't need none of that because we got
the next one lined up right now extra
content end of Zoey if you remember what
happened to Zoey in like the the main
storyline if you you had a choice there
but Zoey got consumed into this weird
crystalline thing and it wasn't really
evident what that was anyway new game
normal I'm good for normal difficulty I
know what I'm doing now so here we go oh
yeah oh this is the moment yeah
[Music]
I had to use my head there's only one
left
it's fine it was perfect
I'm sure there's someone who can help
this is my home apparently I belong I'll
send help
don't bother there won't be anyone left
to help
oh yeah that if you pick TV to get the
thing she that happens and I don't know
what that is and I don't know why
Evelyn's doing that to her sister but uh
no that's bad Oh Zoey bigger she's still
breathing
calling HQ Wow
okay not smart Wow okay goodness wait
how did you punch out to helmeted
soldiers
listen to me we're here to help no I
don't believe you boy
tell me what kind of help comes
you know helicopter gunship you don't
know what you're talking about
you don't get it you think I don't know
who you people are
with all these monsters running around
here tell me where'd they come from
it's not what you think
you don't understand I don't understand
you see the girl back there look that
damn my brother's little girl my niece
you want to stand here family is a
righteous talk and you ain't gonna kill
my family
see daddy something I can abide [ __ ]
sake she's infected she's dying and
we're both gonna [ __ ] die right now I
ain't dead yet boy so I figure you
better do something about it
for I feel you two little friends
outside okay there's a cure your lie to
me we were on our way to get her
treatment and you [ __ ] that up
when you jumped us I probably still
waiting for us right now
where
man he's a big muscular southern man I
am tall
it's just what it's like to be tall I'm
so big Zoe no it's awfully convenient
that this weird crystalline growth
covered your boobs and almost a skirt
like things so that's nothing I guess
are you just stay there big guys gonna
go Splore it hit my my journal that was
no Gator I saw today was out checking
the lines when I saw had one I saw
pulled it up and steady with some sludge
covered god knows what with huge teeth
and toes trying to get at me saw punch -
[ __ ] teeth then before dude never
thought I'd see with my own eyes goddamn
government doing secret experiments on
people and animals no doubt about it
explain those helicopter flying around
recently well this other big said
because if he's been living around here
his brother is and the whole family has
been infected for like years now like
two years wasn't it was he not paid a
visit ever since what is that o.o bap
boom boom boom boom boom boom go get you
just gonna be whoa ow
what the hell came at me it came at me
oh yeah
good to keep my guard up yeah I gotta
keep my guard up like this that's really
gonna do it for me please tell me this
is just gonna be all fisticuffs oh yes
oh yes oh yeah Joe yes Joe ah Joe you
you big bastard oh yes Oh Joe
yeah what's this okay Joe biker Elsie
ask is a football or
how to kill those things bodies are
tough but heads are soft punch did it as
many fast punches impossible left right
right with some fast right jabs work
good right left right then a stroke
knocks him out heads crushed easily
under foot when they fall down crowd
just eager behind we're not looking to
take them out without a fight I love it
I love it I love it I love it oh I love
it oh I love it love it do I need to
visit the outhouse left right right oh
there's the brass hello it makes critter
with cam fluid I have a scientist I will
make goop juice out of this
just take a grab you wrap it in some
clams why you got sweet goop juice so
put it everywhere
ain't gonna be no problems with you when
you got grub juice ooh that Gator I have
you know I got my Gator football game
you play I get I don't even the grub
critter
where did I find that man if he's in
another oh yeah oh my god oh wow whoops
that is the map how do I get the map up
what that yeah wait I'm crashing a
barely a finisher Wow
okay that doesn't seem efficient but you
know it is awesome as all hell alright
let me just get some of this grub juice
cuz I wasn't thinking
okay that's good right on my hitting
hand
I call this hit II and I call this 50
don't make it hit in fist in mad fist
you're gonna give you the old two three
we're gonna skip right over one oh yeah
oh yeah you don't see me behind this
poison ivy do you do you son here covers
50 called it's the stealthy kill real
quiet-like oh that one didn't even know
nothing about my silent taunt afterwards
it's a real quiet
die [ __ ] yeah nobody know ain't
nobody know is the greatest thing I have
ever seen in my entire life
I'm the greatest thing where's Mason
grub and grabbing this tree huh I need
more chem fluid before I'm able to make
the goop juice I need break Oh
oh damn I hit doll collect effigies
daddy's hitting sticks
I call this hit II what same as my lefty
hit e-50 this is also hit II look at him
oh look at hit ego I call his tiny
punchy paw you sack of [ __ ] all right
mmm grub fluid got some grub piss it's
just piss that's all his grub grab yes
got critic got that [ __ ] [ __ ] grub juice
oh I got a flashlight apparently a bap
someone trying to punch you through a
while huh you ain't gonna punch it
through way hello friend
you look like you could use some punches
care for a type infection well I don't
know Radley what that means but
yeah what ass that's right that's good
dude that grub oh he already made his
own grub juice or that's gross but oh
well oh right oh those were some faster
oh don't grub around your head grub
you're on your dong what I heard that
who did dad hello
grub grub grub grab grab grab brother
grub grab Oh would you grab Oh get some
drew fisty get some for me top-50 party
alright
whoa hey grub grub grub grub grub grub
grub no no no no yeah I love this so
much it's so fun
who's there who's there alright well now
that I learnt you something good you
ain't gonna go back now to my home
that's what I know for 113 100% certain
that guy back home probably dead cuz I
left him whoo don't know the power fist
in Haiti I've done punch the air and it
made that fall well maybe I shouldn't
let my Gators oh God oh my Gators
oh no it's hideous tea Oh Oh Steve oh
damn it damn it damn it
Dagny oh well this ain't good but okay
priorities first
that's the proper insertion point for
cures I know this okay she needs a full
dose they feel completely that doesn't
make sense
craters man oh you laid all the critters
get away oh hey you ain't critter oh you
critter food now huh can't worry about
that none definitely not my fault all
right come on
come along Zoe that's mine alright see
ya
I can't oh man hit E and fisty are all
used up right now
alright fine let's go to here a bus stop
that man it's still by the fire Zoe
alright see yeah no joke huh maybe you
shouldn't have punched those government
employees
okay it's okay now Zoe
is it okay doesn't seem okay I'm just
gonna guess by the conflagration and the
ominous zombies standing right there but
you off you want to go with oh oh you
want some a hidden fish do you come find
me
will you come find me will you come find
me you'll find me you knows where I live
wait a minute hmm they blew up where I
live that ain't good okay dad sold your
boy by the way he's dead very dead want
to clarify that he very extremely did
although not sure didn't check he met he
got some grub juice aa good question
you know if this guy just didn't
interfere everything would be hunky-dory
somebody okay you gonna punch your way
through him this time
oh that's a good slurp I don't like the
sound of that slurp clunk all right
yeah they got that wall up fast holy
hell
also again what this guy that was just
punching punching for the past two years
straight like this isn't self
reclusiveness it's isolated away only
punching forever and ever
all right Zoe I don't know where we're
going and I don't know why but okay I'm
not staring at your boob I'm just
looking where I'm still not now Gator
all right
here I go I'll punch you later Gator
okay duh that's not good yeah hey come
on come on now nice I don't know about
that there's a conveniently nice couch
here my statistic Goucher I don't know
about that no no but I'll save okay
whoo-hoo almost punched that shave and
whoops almost destroyed it before I
recorded my op welp there goes thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm out
of time for this episode but I
appreciate you guys being here and
there's gonna be a fun one so thanks
again let me know what you think down
the comments below and as always I will
see you
in the next video
[Music]